So why are we working on
the recognition problem?
Well, recognition,
it's a fundamental part of perception.
Whether you're talking about robots,
autonomous agents, whatever.
The idea is that the ability
to know what things are and
therefore how you want to interact
with them, is it really important?
It, it's gives you
a way of organizing and
thinking about the visual
content of the world.
And perhaps even more importantly,
it's a very human way of
thinking about things, right?
I, I give objects labels, and
if I tell you to go pick up the cup and
put it away,
you know what I'm talking about.
So we want our machines and
systems to be able to do that too.
So for example, autonomous agents,
and here's a pair.
The one on the left is a robot.
This is from Karlsruhe, and Rüdiger
Dillmann's work on, domestic robot.
And this robot has to be able to go
pick up cups out of dishwashers.
It has to know that
there is a dishwasher.
It has to see that, oh,
I put that cup down, it didn't make it,
I'm going to go get it.
It has to be able to be told
that the cups go over there.
All right?
So if I'm going to communicate
about these things to that robot,
I'm going to use labels that
talk about these objects.
Even in autonomous systems.
So here, I think this was, Stanley.
I think that was one of the Urban Grand
Challenge vehicles, one of the winners.
It has to understand
that this is a thing and
this thing we know
that it's called a car.
All it needs to know is it's this thing
that it's learned a lot of things about.
And that this kind of thing which
are cars do things like continue moving,
might stop, have certain behaviors,
likewise that this object there might
move in your way and it uses a lot
of machine learning to do that.
Maybe not quite the traditional
labeling in the way.
But the idea is that these autonomous
agents understand the nature of,
of the world being carved up in objects.
And I can communicate about them and
it can autonomously detect them.
Labeling people.
That's a recognition task.
This is something we do all the time.
You know, every time you tag folks
on Facebook, and it both finds that
it is a face, and we'll talk
about detection in a little bit.
But also,
you might want to know who it is.
Peter Belhumeur and folks did these
digital field guides where you'd like to
be able to like maybe take a picture
of a leaf and say you know,
what kind of leaf is that?
If you're into that nature
kind of thing which I'm not.
But it's this idea of being able to,
to recognize things.
And maybe you've found some
really expensive stuff online and
you say please find me more
shoes that look like this.
For any relatives of mine that I'm
still continuing to subsidize.
So, you could use computer vision to
help you find less expensive shoes.
Just saying.
All right.
The idea of, you know,
can I find something that
looks kind of like that, so
I have to recognize that it's a shoe.
Maybe it's already labeled as a shoe,
recognize the type, that kind of thing.